lucky episode number 13 and we are in
the building glorious Sunday at the
usual time of the usual suspects at the
round table let's start off with their
non aggro gamer my brother from another
mother co-host with the encode most Lord
addicts in the building was going to all
addict what else he's chillin no no no
what happened no what happened was the
user when I loaded up the YouTube one on
on the actual browser to see the chat I
started hearing you talk again from the
replay and I thought you're still
introducing me would I yeah after watch
so just just chillin just kind of tired
from work last night I hate you a little
Italian I hear you and then of course we
got Illuminati confirmed all man Lord
sovereign in the building what is going
on low summer a bit what's good man
doing good don't very good I'm coming
away from Zelda for a little while I
load that would be today and of course
one of our most requested Lords excess
gamer the premium experience himself
lower kings in the building what's good
ol ok what's going on man i'm off to
seven day fast so I'm really clearing
ahead um I didn't want to bring
something out here in the bottom working
should we already debunk you know you
your list being real because it wasn't
called chemical warfare and it's called
World War two the technicality I feel
like that is it my friend we cannot run
because colleges fuckong chemical
warfare I what I agree that he had
hashtag fear the incorrect list what why
does that let's scare you so much my for
me it's yo girl you
no no you need to stop is a call of duty
game listen this a call to home you can
call it bloom boys nice out basic outfit
listen how kill what can't you trust
back step easy Sickology no clothes you
trying to nitpick and you talk to your
right no no you know what happened no
happened because i got i love how you
just jump all into my intro with this
thank you oh you know uh you know what
happened what it was was it was a game
that blew your mind and it was the Dark
Soul joint that scared the crap out of
you and you said oh my god there's
actually a Dark Soul came comments and
I'm gonna show it there's a little my
grandpa jumping into my intro and you
know it cutting my intro show like I
ever listen it like that like i have a
trip you when you walking in the door I
put out my Fred lookie this clearly
missed last me I was heavily active and
i would say activities trees tho those
podcasts i needed you there lord King
you wanna don't go shut up shut up there
hell it was a great one we had last uh
but uh definitely looking was missed
fans are craving that matchup that slit
so getting real quick everything what's
up with our case motel or kiss moves in
a building what's up you know um I just
want to say like what everybody's been
playing I know for me off to the jump um
it's been a little bit more switch
getting I've been messing around with
the Bomberman our sister 60 frame per
second upgrade tremendous difference
playing around with dad I'm actually
I've been touching a little fast armed
ex and I wanted to get some mom actually
want to get some marvel ultimate
alliance on because the Marvel heroes
drop and the debate isn't at least for
ps4 first but I gotta wait for the xbox
one one but what the Lord's been a plane
let's start with you Lord attic
don't you play Greek or it was playing
Oh a halo wars to OC like a trip up
right hey sorry I apologize we both
stating facts you stating facts are
playing halo war soon i'm staying fact
that you lost the bet start yet like you
crazy you know what it is you know that
i got a place this solely on the
shoulders of LOCOG neato i'm gonna show
to the book like you know because locog
needles have you terrified of bets
because you ready hell on destiny too
and he has you in these streets right
now cuz you seven hundred dollars in so
he has you in the street we don't have
anything on the line room this this
there's no money involved there's no
isn't is this nothing all it is all it
is is you checking it off on my back and
you probably looking at not a lot of
money mike pretty messy it so this is
all right so that be ready to check it
off on my back you lost no money here is
fine it's okay you could come off the
ledge because you my friend are
traumatized from law cognito time tryna
for the spotlight summer else like it's
that late no you're traumatized so
everywhere saying but what have you been
playing hello sorry let's get right into
it so i ah yeah hbu playing a little bit
of a wonder boy the dragon strap on us
which for me basically i consider me a
playstation 4 switch gamer until scorpio
comes out I'm not touching anything
alone England's face xboxes gets collect
a little best now I have cockroaches
secure your xbox stand
boy wonder boy is something else mad at
me for somebody who was a big time sega
master system fan to see that game
remade the way it's been remade it's a
it's a beautiful thing it controls
beautifully it looks beautiful I mean it
old-school gameplay for sure but er um
man it's pretty I've heard good things
look guys look ipod soon as i told me
good things about it so I scene II
picked up as well so um lord King what
have you been playing nice me I've been
playing the wolf among us no I started
going back to my arm I telltale games
because you know guardians of the galaxy
from Telltale was just released so I'm
trying to clear up all my Telltale Games
finish of the both walking dead series I
um I'm doing the wolf among us and then
right after I finish that I'm going into
batman then I'm gonna go to the
Guardians rabbits real good I recommend
that one I'd be I had a good time with
Batman actually gonna like that one
that's cool yeah you actually being you
on the same track with that because I'm
I wanted to pick up Guardians this week
but I said you know what I got so much
on my tail tail backlog that I need to
finish and you're like you i need to do
wolf among list i was one that i still
haven't missed and how would you heard
it's amazing i gotta do it I gotta do it
you know I heard good things about it so
you say I hung out stuff wolf among us I
haven't touched Borderlands like none of
that stuff so yeah nice cool so we're
gonna jump right into it a lot of stuff
going on this week in the gaming
industry so we're going to jump things
off immediately so first up the bat is
on what's been going on with the ESA and
for those who don't know it's the
entertainment software association they
have um you're generally responsible for
holding down a three and those great
events that we like and they owned and
operated so they just came out with
these all bunch of statistics that I've
know a pretty interesting I wanted to
bring to the round table so the first
off the bat with this um the essays
annual report was about saying that
seventy-four percent of gamers and gain
content purchases are digital
seventy-four percent which I thought was
a pretty large number
as well as some other key facts that
they actually talked about he said on
the average gamer is 35 years old that
was another one that kind of surprise me
they talked about on sixty-seven percent
of u.s. households on a device that is
used to play video games they mentioned
that women aged 18 and older represent a
significant greater portion of game
playing population than boys that same
age and they talked about how just
basically like one of the people I think
looking like this one one of three
people were frequent gamers said they
would like to buy virtual reality within
the next year and that on the loss of a
little like a fifty percent of our
gamers frequent play multiplayer games
at least once in a week so I don't know
if one of us got a chance to check out
any of these statistics but those are
the key ones and I know that stood out
to me so I wanted to bring it to the
table anybody can jump in with the
Lord's think about the ESA and digital
sales and all these statistics that and
get up I wanted to jump in on the the VR
and you know I was going to the Rick and
Morty just dropped off anybody that was
very interested in to you know Rick and
Morty world it's a lot of east eggs
inside of that VR if you get a chance to
check it out I went to my boys house and
checked out his vibe and it is amazing
like I've been saying I can't wait to my
media room is set up so I can properly
uh pick up my vibe and play that but the
VR space is definitely expanding and
once the you know they started picking
up IPS with that must catch saved this
rick and marty is very huge so once they
started picking up those type of
licensees and slapping it on games that
that shows very good promise when it
comes to the future of VR to me mm-hmm
absolutely i was definitely from one out
of three i thought that was actually a
big deal now what did you feel about
looking about like just like the average
game of being 35 years old and whoa you
know digital games particularly those
two i want to get your feedback on
especially well okay it makes sense for
the average gamer to be 35 and above
you know because of financial reasons
you know video games aren't cheap they
actually go up in price yearly to be
honest with you you know we we noticed
that it started off it was like 49 99 or
whatever and we started getting games
that were 69 on an average so you say 59
is the average now you know with taxes
and stuff like that so you know average
consumers purchasing three to four games
a year you have to have a stable job you
have to have internet you factor in all
these prices and it lends to a mature
individual that can hold down all these
financial stipulations that come with
playing video games nowadays so yeah 35
works oh cool any other lords feedbacks
well a lord addict would you feel about
these stats is going on right now he's
esa streets I think it's pretty pretty
standard and we pretty much done the
majority of that mmm nothing anything
nothing particularly surprised you um
what about like the digital's aspect now
I've always known that now you are the
resident young buck at the round table
so what did you feel about getting
overshadowed it at a 35 year old 35 + oh
geez playing with you how'd you feel
about that oh I mean it's not like
they're saying every game was 30
something which others in sleazy friends
I mean maybe they're going if you look
dirty son because I look 30 something so
I mean they don't I know it I'd look
like the younger that's got a footy you
know what it is though is it what
they're saying is it's just how do you
feel being a minority that's what the
question really should be there how do
you feel every time you walk in a room
that the guys are just so much older
than you more wiser than you you know
you come in you know a little bit more
nimble a little bit more fast and quick
to the droid you know how does it feel I
don't know we take the conversation
scuba know anything not not my topic I'm
just driving in Louis every way we feel
about you yes a statistics everything
you can see it I think it what it proves
is that Microsoft was right Microsoft
one on the right track when they
announced the xbox one in 2013 they did
a bit a few things wrong in terms of how
they I'm Polly message did uncle
obviously coming out first with all that
with all that media stuff and not
talking about games hurt them although I
feel the middle generation you don't
bring out a game machine without games
coming so people blew that out of
proportion the whole unfriendliness
about about trading games and things
like that that didn't come off as
consumer friendly at all but all the
other stuff they try to implement it's
coming to pass now it's coming back and
if you look at those numbers it there as
high as they are seventy four percent
you have to assume that's a lot of
PlayStation gamers the people who didn't
want this people who can make it Oh made
a big whoop about having uh you know an
entire digital future and not having
physical game so i think i think it was
obvious that it was coming um you know
so i think it's a little surprising that
it's happened as fast that the adoption
has happened as fast i honestly thought
he's gonna be kind of a longer tail for
this but yeah all in all though it
doesn't really surprise me and I just
see that number growing and growing no
more and more yeah but I mean I'm with
the loads on this I think they lost
seven are definitely rihanna is that I
doctor dr. Park far as the microsoft
thing I was just laughing because um I
mean Lord Kings had this discussion in
the past where everyone was so I mean
let's be honest Microsoft got demon eyes
with the initial you never video with
the whole digital thing and oh it's
gonna be numb the messaging we know was
clearly bad you know but the the actual
execution of what the foresight for the
future was was not they clearly saw this
digital age moving forward in the
convenience and you just got the sales
you got
Spring Sale the holiday sale you know
games gold all this stuff and you know
everybody's really taking advantage of
it so that's one thing that I definitely
see that they were definitely
visionaries in terms of that and it's
proof that people are adopting it and
it's so funny because you know a lot of
these games that we play our always
online games you notice iddin it yeah
these know things that we were so
resistant or the gaming community was so
resistant back then at 2013 5 2014 and
he's just funny to see how he's just
steadily rising and got come into tech
question yeah go for it girl from ok I
got a question do you think Microsoft
should a lot yeah they got vilified for
telling truth is the thing this is this
is what I'm talking about this is the
parent syndrome right the parent knows
best right the child doesn't know crap
so the parent knows best and I feel like
Microsoft being a parent you know
Elizabeth no just be facetious with this
Microsoft being a parent and they know
where everything is heading you know
they put the marketing dollars into the
situation they put the research dollars
into the situation they put everything
behind making sure that the company is
very successful and all the researchers
and everything said ok we're going
digital is going this way and soon we're
going to always be online do you think
that in them imposing that you know
strict nature of the drm quote unquote
everybody was fearful love which is
always online now your xboxes oh when
you click it it's always online your
PlayStation is always online it switches
always online yeah you could play them
offline but the availability of your
friends list or somebody jumping in
saying hey let's join this party and the
accessibility that everyone has to you
at any given time is more beneficial for
you as a gamer and microsoft
foreshadowed this and saw this ahead of
every other company and was ready to
move
her and got demon eyes for it and we're
at that point anyway I didn't I think
it's the way it was message it was just
the way it was message like everything
when it came the difference in price the
difference in power on the way you know
when Don matrix is yeah I got a system
for you it's called the xbox 360 that's
a big darn sure it's just how they it's
how they messaged it I I guarantee you
if Phil have been in front of this
messaging it would have been the same
thing just a lot prettier and with a
bigger smile on his face and he would
have reply again anyway and in all
likelihood this had the strings in
nature of the trading and stuff like
that that probably would not have been
in place did you know they would fill
these things he tries to make things as
forward-facing and ads and as cost
consumer friendly as possible and that's
not done on matrix that's just now how
he handles things so the messaging would
have come on differently again I don't
know if if the conversation about the
difference in power and the fact there
was a hundred dollars more because of
connect that still would have caused a
lot of issues in the gaming community I
think that apart from eliminating the
connect before they released it that's
the only way they could have alleviated
that they were still got throws him
money I thought it was the money I
thought it was the cheap nation sticking
my arm in there and Rob me listen 500
400 I mean it holds me Emily it was way
and then you couple that with bad
messaging you know people with this
misconception I mean I remember people
saying things to the nation like you
know it's Spygate you know they had a
camera extinguish want you online like
it was so much fear mongering in
conjunction with the bad message and of
course the Don telling us oh we have a
360 if you don't like it yes you know it
was just it was a perfect form of bad
things but to your point King I do agree
with you is just like you know
microsoft's had the foresight to see the
vision they did tell the truth or where
they wanted to go and less let's call a
spade a spade you know Sony's vision was
the same yeah
get him and I remember that day our late
yeah I'd I remember that day like it was
yesterday that III and their press
conference was delayed an hour and as
the reports came out your sheet in these
guys and you know treat written at the
time those guys that were in charge you
know that the main thing is when they
saw the negative backlash microsoft guy
they said hey what can we do can we get
rid of this drm can we get rid of this
camera and it was just a perfect storm
to scramble in the last minute to change
their messaging because as everyone
knows who's picked up a surprising and
the pricing exactly so anyone knows
that's picked up a ps4 when you picked
up your ps4 day one guess what you had a
day one patch guess what to remove drm
so all that stuff with seven hours that
was seven hours i will never forget me
turning on that system and it's a chill
out for seven hours oh yes I good it is
it's funny to see how these things play
out I just thought the VSA reports were
very interesting you know just seeing
this tremendous rise in digital sales
and you know just people finally getting
at the time to realize that you know
what I can you know do this from the
comfort of my own house you know there's
a lot of advantages everything you know
as Lord addict is point out you know the
game sharing is huge I know like we
talked about that a lot so on and then
what the other things you know as far as
the reports went to touch on real quick
was um you know the average gamer thing
that did surprise me I did surprise me
you know as as as the og one of the oh
Jesus fun fact has brought here the van
Taylor I was actually surprised I'm like
wow this is no longer a young man's game
you know like oh I've seen it though I
mean we've seen it but he's just it was
surprising to see the number and I'm
like wow that's pretty interesting that
kind of things and even the um you know
the rise of female gamers you know I
thought that was really pretty
interesting and stuff like that so just
some real cool trends they do the mobile
games so you know a lot of the female
population is coming from them too yeah
you got you got a justice rise man
didn't act with them being a high
percentage more than you know was it
over the 18 that
man like I was like wow that is as crazy
as deep like I didn't I didn't realize
that so as you show how the industry is
growing and trends moving so that was
interesting so then he loves and he got
anything more on there before you jump
into the next one nope oh good all right
next one of Lord added cuz I know he's
got a lot to say about Xbox fan SP ask
her what way oh man oh I'm gonna be the
opportunity to step in first King
because I know it's still on your chest
and you said there's chest look exhibits
Chairez money wombo my man money um how
can I say this without coming off like a
condescending ass oh I love to disclaim
this is this is because you know what
I'm not gonna like chris / it was
fantastic you know and I don't want to
rest his soul ii on Chris hands it just
happens that you know he laid an egg and
it's not his fault because he wasn't
actively managing people walking in the
door like he was doing last year when it
went off without a hitch like Jennifer
on what what's going on with fanfare
what happened well let me tell you what
went down what went down was okay the
fact that they switched it up this year
from standing outside in the mall and
earning his stripes to sitting on your
couch on your butt and clicking on
Twitter to to to get your tickets the
fact that you know our people was
willing and ready and able to camp out
and brought day tickets on flights and
book hotel rooms and ready to do this
ready to put they bars up for Microsoft
and waved a flag and they get out in
these streets and represent like you
supposed to if you can't wait 24 hours
in a line and hold your urine and hold
your defecation and sit down on your
butt and chill and earn your way to a
fan fest then you don't need to beat it
they decided that dish here no no no I
did not go too far cuz nobody i decided
did not god damn i should i should have
went really harder because this year
they decided to cater to the soft
individual the individual that i can't
be there for 12 hours and you know my
bladder is small and I i get i get
nervous in large crowds guy that's the
guy that you started catering to the
softest among us the weakest of mothers
you know xbox fingers are strong we're
able to stand up and take care this
weibull to represent our flag you have
the true xbox fans last year and this
year i guarantee you they won't be loud
they won't be strong they won't be
enforced because they'll be soft because
they clicked on twitter and got day
tickets now how many as I really feel
like dick Jones I feel good let's get to
the part how many you think out of these
people that get these tickets online
actually gonna show up like they're
gonna do impose no no it's torture
charge of one hundred fifty dollars I
don't care break their wallet break them
in break a mini because this this is
this is Microsoft soft cash grab why
don't you put down at the bottom if you
don't show up we charging you five
hundred dollars let's see how many
people really click and really is ready
to go that little hundred dollar mark
how did some church now I just want to
jump in on what you said for a second
there's been chirps as far as I've been
hearing these and these gaming streets
you know for people like us who are FS
regulars and they're saying you guys
have a sense of entitlement Microsoft
doesn't owe you anything and you know I
don't exactly and then it was like you
know the it's it's really no big deal
what happened do what do you say to
people who would have that sentiment to
say this is not a big deal that
everyone's fan fest website then got
voided so basically for what your
sponsor let's give it to those people to
say that I feel entitled because I'm
renting right now let me explain one
thing to you let's say a di'taykan
day off and I said I'm gonna sit here
and i'm gonna click do the twitter wait
how they want to do it and it's fine
okay all right now when I got through
when I put all my information in and
when I made it may got my confirmation
and he said did she got your ticket then
I felt safe and I was secure right then
let's say I booked my flight and I did
everything that I had to do I did my
part what's up with chetan now you will
penalize me one hundred and fifty
dollars on my and if I didn't show up if
I use this ticket and did whatever fo
gazing with it but you gonna tell me
that it's your site this is your event
this is your party this is your planning
you messed up because you didn't stress
test this beforehand hmm you didn't do a
soft try out before him again you're
under estimating your your arm your
celebrity you keep under estimating your
celebrity at my expense yeah yeah what
if you why do I hmm if you look at why
do I have to every time feel like I'm
repping the [ __ ] kid in the party
why everybody else you know why
everybody else has their stuff go off
without a hitch why everybody else every
other company goes oh and i know you're
ambitious and i know you try your best
and you want to do the best for your
fast but brother check it out first
before you have everybody feeling all
great about themselves that they got a
ticket that they got in and that they're
happy about it and then you call me you
yank the rug from under us because you
messed up mmm enough yes what do you say
what's what say you Lord Syron you look
quite a curious about your this is this
is kind of a new experience for you
right because the fan fest it no I
completely agree you know why I took off
last the day last week to be on my own
connection beyond my home connection
exactly to be sure to be sure that I
could have the best possible chance to
my ticket I got through my lord lord
mardonius also got through yeah mono he
is in the building you know I was on the
bill to do good as I'm communicating all
of you guys through messenger and what
not seem like everybody got through so I
was like yes I can't believe it we're
all going with this is this is amazing
hmm and then as as the story progressed
throughout the day it was just more and
more negativity and more and more rumors
about what was going to happen and it is
just it's ridiculous it's absolutely I
agree completely lord King this is
something you know this was gonna happen
you knew this was gonna happen you knew
you weren't gonna get bombarded with
people mmm how are you not prepared for
that and then how is your answer then oh
well you know what anybody who got a
confirmation of for long confirmation
saying congratulations here's your
ticket now forget it you don't know it's
just it's completely it's completely it
just shows that you know they listened
to I guess they listen to some criticism
of how things were done in the past and
they tried to improve things and it is
they did not prepare for this and it's
ridiculous that you would not prepare
for this because as much goodwill as you
as you have going into into III with the
Scorpio announcement and everything new
that you're promising this kind of it
this is thought you know this is just it
just feels like it's ours the whole
situation to be perfectly honest I
honestly this coming Wednesday I don't
know that we have a chance in hell now
yeah I mean the chances are really it's
gonna be brutal I mean because it you
know it was a dedicated fan base that
was aware of it was on it so now that
they botched it and now a little bit
more attention has been botched you know
what to it now they doing just a
one-shot thing for my understanding now
it's right it's now it's just it you
know holder 101 one shot no more arm
drops so you know it's gonna be tough
it's really gonna be tough you know I
honestly i underst
and I understand the limited numbers in
terms of getting people into the into
the briefing but honestly off of this
they need if they're gonna continue fan
fest and again they don't owe us
anything they don't owe us anything it's
a positive to go and the fact that they
provided is cool it's just if you know
what if you're gonna provide something
if you do something do it right and
that's just like and and considering
considering the lengths people have to
go to to get to this that you should
always take that into consideration so
my thing is what they need to do is yeah
okay four or five hundred people for for
fan fest generally and III briefing but
they should also expand all the other
activities to include other xbox fans
that maybe they cannot get into the
briefing in that way you kind of you
know you make other people happy also
it's gonna cost you money but i think
it's the way to go not fair you i feel
let me let me a lot lord atkin because i
know how I'm ready to golf too so what
did you learn is already going for Laura
either you hold you hold your gun ready
yeah yeah all right I don't issues with
what happened I understand that certain
stuff happens you know stuff that they
couldn't anticipate I'm with a I'm with
Lord King when you know they should have
took more precautions to to anticipate
the traffic that their servers are going
to get and what's funny is if you look
today before people were asking them are
you sure that your servers can handle
something like this it chris is all true
to say we got this we are to for custody
okay so obviously I you know it's
something like that you can never know
how many people truly going to be
interested to what happens my issue is
the five hours between we messed up to
we make an announcement holla let's go
because get at it you had and then you
know I was talking to people and they
were saying you know if I see people on
Twitter saying if you went out and
bought tickets uh that's on you i'm like
so let me get this straight you know i
live on the east coast so you know i
didn't get it but let's say you know
someone else gets that ticket and they
see the confirmation no announcements
been made to say
this is void so I'm going to wait two
weeks to get my ticket know you could be
more no I'm going straight to now your
line and straight to hotel booked it
right then and there because my store
sells write anything exactly and you
know ICP they'll explain really ours not
to cut you thought it was three hours
for three or herself even made a
statement that there was something wrong
so between that and three hours fights
could have been booked you know hotels
the whole thing and I think that is a
great point you're making like that has
not been overstated sorry go jump back
in again I had just you know that and
you know people sit there I you know
it's like you know when uh when Lord
kill or cognitive Brownstein title thing
it's like I don't really understand how
gamers that went through a process the
way you're supposed to got a
confirmation and it's like it's like you
know you guys have said multiple it's
like winning the lottery twice it's like
why should I have to win it twice why my
being penalized because you guys can't
run something correctly it you know I
did they not think this would happen and
it's like yeah I brought up in a party a
couple days ago I said it's like it's
like you know the NFL hosting a similar
event that's like the first 500 get get
a Super Bowl ticket and then they end up
do some [ __ ] like this and then you got
like a thousand people that have a super
bowl ticket see if you put it in a
perspective like you know a lot of
people they like games but they're not
that serious so this isn't that serious
big of a deal to them and then you got
the people that's in media that don't
really want fan fest there anyway
because it's taking media seats so
obviously they're not going to want them
there so you know yeah you gotta put in
perspective they want you know big
sports people imagine if you had a super
bowl ticket your hand in three or four
hours later after the preparation though
where you're supposed to they say oh we
messed up well you could have told me
this five hours ago like why do you know
stop this so they will do that five
minutes after it went live yeah it was a
scramble because that that's what
happened to us because you know Lord at
it in myself I mean you know as lord
king los sovereign is telling us hey
they got in you guys are
furman we're filling out forms we're
getting the parts with credit card
information and postal codes and that
stops and all of a sudden the site is
just not taking it so you can tell at
that point they were literally
scrambling to shut everything down but
they weren't being transparent they were
just like holy ish something went wrong
will probably let more than the hundred
supposed to be each dropper supposed to
be a hundred people per drop right so
probably at that point it went way past
the 100 there now scrambling to try to
shut the damn okay I get it but at the
point now that the dam is shut you have
to be transparent you have to be very
clear on what's going on it's now three
hours have gone past the only statement
you made is there won't be another drop
and I'm not gonna make me say I want to
come out and say that they even tried to
delete tweets too high they did i'm just
look a good point italy in here little
girl she does let me repeat me and Laura
cognito did not get a ticket we were not
part of the people that got a ticket so
literally like you know when me and him
to get a ticket you know we were kind of
like well at least we get another chance
but you know people are acting like I
can't sympathize with the people that
did if you got a first but you're not
dating but here's the thing when I got
to cut you technically we did you get a
ticket on our screen said
congratulations you that point it should
hold your place in the queue at that
right and that's it like idiot you can't
lose your place after tells you
congratulations that's immuno what they
grab this on show what's up all right
shut up formation right it wasn't no you
know the beginning it had the little
circle that said load act yeah that was
doing the cute but they did it was in
that it was didn't to be there because
that bypassed it and gave everyone that
clicked that a congratulation right but
it was that that advertisement that they
used on the site that is what
facilitated all the people able to rush
in at one time because they said the bay
matter of fact that it was actively
loading it um it fooled the site into
believing that the page wasn't fully up
yet and
those intuitive people that said oh i
see that's an ad loading i don't care
about that let me click over to this
thing in the corner babe i asked that
right and went straight in where is a
hundred the robber would mind loaded his
long ago when i got to the page that
pop-up came up on its own and then and
then and then other people like had that
loading thing and I just said you know
click on that thing in the corner and
then it popped up so I'm like wait a
minute yeah like they was completely
unclear because when you click the
initial supply link all you got was a
please loading you know loading please
wait so any person with common sense
it's like hey I don't want to touch
anything the righteous way let me let it
do its thing me I'm in but the
processing so a lot of people i SAT
there like my foolishness and like I
just SAT there for like least 5-10
minutes I didn't have the balls to touch
anything else Oh touch I go to the right
I'm telling you sign in and I'm like
okay what do you think I got us a sign
his kids smooth calm he's like I got it
and I was like he was like I clicked out
that green box on the right I was like
don't be messing with me kid it looks
like it was don't kick normal saying
that they touch that box on the right to
sign in I was not touching my sort of
been sitting there but I daughter been
still there when I got in there I loaded
it twice I look I said nah nah
something's up click OK did and it was
like congratulations and I swear at that
moment my hands were super sweaty I
never swept from my hands my hands were
super sweaty and I was putting the
information and then once I got that
email I felt I felt like a weight was
lifted off him because you don't pay for
my hotel room I pay for the flights arm
when i said i came i already put the
money away for the time that i'm gonna
be there and whatever ething else was
now worrying about my comrades are they
in
and uh who isn't in yet and how can I
help them that's what work because we
have more drops throughout the day
absolutely and what I definitely don't
really feel for this wednesday yeah well
that you say it's like I said you know
me more cognito everyone in this podcast
all a few of our friends we already had
pre purchases we are going regardless
you know we were relying on the fan fest
to get to the microsoft event but you
know none of us are really blaming
Microsoft for what happened but it's
just like it could have been done better
yeah blaming them they they entrusted
this to a third party website they
handle stuff like this and it seemed
like they weren't paying attention to it
moment to moment and you know and again
it doesn't seem like they stress tested
tested this at all they could have done
this internet on Microsoft's get an
indication of what might happen I mean
come on as many people as they've turned
away from fanfest you guys have been
there in the past couple of years people
who lined up as many people as they have
to turn away they knew that there was
going to be interesting it's especially
with the launch of a new console the
announcement of you counsel people gonna
want to be there hey it's 17 to be
honest with you Lord Cognito has seen
this firsthand and he seen the
progression of the furor me seeing the
progression of the what this is really
happening because he explained the first
year they barely scathed like 200 people
to get there yeah so the next year he
noticed that it was like 300 and some be
without its crazy last year it was nine
hundred and some odd people at eleven
o'clock at night and they only had three
hundred tickets fi and you gotta keep in
mind that when we was at this lady it
was it was crazy seen the amount of
people that came here food we're lost
but a lot like if you feel I want to
jail of it if you let you get so much
man like I said you know I do feel like
you know no one at war I'm
speak for myself I don't blame microsoft
for the whole you know fan fest thing i
do feel like you know you know it's like
you can ask laura Cognito we were
talking and I would you know I was
considering just you know refunding my
flight and taking the l on the on the
hotel was like you know it's me to blame
for being too rash too to get a you know
to buy everything before they announced
anything on fan fest they could have
literally not had a fan fest this year
absolutely I would have been so you know
that's on me but at the same time it's
like they know people fly out to these
things this is something that should
announce you know februari mark your
early on and here so people would know
you know what's going on so you know if
they would have told me something like
that I would have been a little bit more
cautious to go out and spend you know
eleven twelve hundred dollars on flight
and hotel and I would have waited for
the fan fest raffle I never thought they
would take it online and that would
smite you yeah i mean look all the
Lord's I'm which are 1000 you know it's
just like let's let's list again I must
reiterate with Laura exit like Marcus
off is doing something obviously didn't
have to do this is something for the
fans this is a really great experience
we love the press conference anybody
that knows and it's going to e3 look III
itself is great make no mistake but the
press conference it's what it's all
about there is something to be said when
you're on that stage next to fill you
know and he's doing these announcements
live and telling you what's happening
you know as it's going on there's
something to be said to be in the
building when that's happening so that's
the experience everything else is really
good you get to mingle with your xbox
brethren people that we haven't seen in
awhile shot at the Lord cranial shout
out lord ruler you know I'm saying
that's my cali connect out there and
it's good it's like a reunion of
brethren you know so that aspect excuse
me from a camaraderie standpoint you
know is Miss so I'm like okay they doing
it online this year I get it last year
was a mob let's not be without flex is
that like it was it it was a bomb you
don't say and they probably sent to
themselves you know we can't deal with
Lord black magic again he's too rowdy
and we can't do it alone you've
illiterate Xbox things you don't want to
get a check it into that credit a
Microsoft did let a lot of these guys
still into III now they do it online
fine I don't have a problem with that we
all get up be set up in front of our
computers we go through the whole
rigmarole clearly something's going
wrong a lot of people are saying they
winning a lot of people saying they're
having errors then like well that accept
is that three-hour window no response
from Microsoft you know if I would have
went to bed I could have said okay look
my screen said congratulations I got a
screenshot you know like North addict
they took his credit card information
that's another thing a lot of people's
credit card information was taken now
Microsoft fiestar's party website yeah
you don't say about now Microsoft is
claiming you know you know we don't
retain that information there's no way
for us to check that I'm not saying
they're lying I'm just saying there's no
way for us to check it but anyone at
that point will say okay look maybe they
just had an error and at that point
we're still good right but what ends up
happening is now all of a sudden we have
that three-hour window now all of a
sudden it's like okay everything's
voided everyone's thoughts from ground
zero you know between that three hours
like lord King said flight getting
booked hotels getting worked you know
and here's my thing what the hell is the
reward going to be for the people who
you put in this position you can't just
say okay let's go back on Wednesday what
is it next Wednesday twelve o'clock one
drop it boo digital code may be like no
better not be no no save blue [ __ ]
sorry I'm telling you right now like for
real for real no I know what I think
they're gonna do and I think this is for
the people that got the confirmation
email um I think they're going to give
them some type of pass to get into the
event on monday listen i don't know i
mean here's the things i was thinking to
myself okay if I'm putting myself at
Microsoft
and you made this mistake and you've got
these people who've got confirmation
that are not going because this mistake
this error on your part how do you make
it right so listen in a perfect scenario
yeah like I would love all of us to be
in the Galen Center killer heavy as as a
mere kol pagana thing I don't think it's
happening I think it's moving the 500
the only thing i was thinking i'll be
less let's be honest because they they
were asking for our credit card
information only for the solar purposes
if you cancel they were charging 150
knots right we got that confirmation
right so at this we should get something
of like value for the people of the box
please listen and also here's the other
I don't know first party game some kind
of first-party some type of first-party
to promote the oak Oh microsoft points
or something that equal from a digital
standpoint that thing because here's the
day let me limit for the people who
listen to podcast right now say yo
you're out of control Microsoft doesn't
owe you anything here's the thing this
is why I gotcha manisha sent me an email
cuz I call that customer service level
or sovereign gave me an email that xbox
fan fest I attach my screenshot saying
that I want I attach my URL saying that
I successfully got in and it was just
giving me a postal code error right all
these things saying I want I could have
literally walked away from my computer
not check twitter again and think it was
i was good you said i'm saying they sent
me an email stating oh you know mr.
cognito oh we're sorry what's going on
you know we're trying to get to the
bottom and you don't book anything i got
that email like what was it Lord Attica
was it like a full 24 hours later day
around no way later if you oh if you
thought you got something like that
you're not what you're getting it like
five minutes later not a day later a day
later so the fact that their customer
service sent me a date and then is
begging me oh we please don't don't book
any flight you know we're gonna figure
this thing out this they already knew
they messed up mm-hmm now again they are
telling people to take legal action
against Microsoft that's on you all I'm
saying is
as a good faith and a good gesture to
the community they need to do something
that's all I'm saying because this was
an error on their end and if they have
let's go back to the table and we all
know it's going to be very difficult
this wednesday i just think the ones
being that like I felt like was a little
slap in the face is this they're still
using a hundred promotion purposes I'm
like you mess up on the way you're
distributing these and you still keep a
hundred for your promotional purposes I
was like the least thing you guys could
have didn't store that hundred in the
raffle like that's the least because
good look I you know I really like money
Rumble he's a good guy like I don't want
to throw my bus i'm not blaming him he's
just a he's blaming money of virtually
he is the face that we associated iron
ores podcast do not a completely shut
out the muddy river i give them a pound
every III when i see you you know I know
me no responsible for the system you
know me money Rumble you see me I I
money rubble I know you're like a you're
seeing the tweets money rubber it seem
like we all know let me bring this to
the loans what I was offered what do you
think they can do provided we don't get
in which is what you think they're gonna
do yeah asking what am I going to do is
love what I said situation is proposed
yeah they need to they need to obviously
some sort of digital game or something
like that but beyond that people are
still going um like I said before they
need to consider either you're gonna go
all the way to the left and eliminate it
completely because there's too much of a
hassle or you're gonna do what I think
is the right thing is you expand you
expand the number of people that you
allow and to the other activities that
you associate with fan fest and you say
okay well 500 first 500 first come first
serve we'll be able to get into the
briefing in addition to everything else
that we give you an fan fest and then
another 500 or so Kim parts
tube8 everything else in fan fest and I
think another thing what it is its own
in the color catcher free vouchers for a
no go three visors for school for you
don't don't be giving out some free Xbox
Scorpio vouchers man because people are
going to give her haha don't you let the
black let me let me let me say this
right let me see this let's say let's
say let's let's play devil's advocate
here don't say Microsoft yeah you you
get in for those 500 people they get in
to fear fest yeah right let's say all
those people get in and at the end
Microsoft poles and an Oprah and
everyone look under your chair he'll get
a Scorpio yo get a Scorpio you'll get a
Scorpio let's say those 500 people get a
Scorpio let's say you mr. salty is
sitting there who has a confirmation
[ __ ] your flight lost your money and you
didn't get in what happens then what
goes on today so good bc show me so I
feel entitled then they don't owe me
nothing then that's how bombers and
stuff happening back don't do it I did
better not my money Rumble this goes out
to you listen I'm stopping you're
bleeding now if your thoughts in your
head was to put a Scorpio under the
chair scrap that door now it's not do
this don't do it working are you say you
already man it--um away you don't rubber
i'ma tell I I defy anybody in this room
to tell me if they don't get in and they
find out the people that do get in next
week your Scorpios under the chair what
is gonna be like
[Laughter]
regular chat raised eyebrow yeah not to
mention me only legit we tell you at the
end of Richard's are gonna be bomb I'm
standing on the healing center with the
hoodies up big of you podcast as
evidence against me in the loss I'll
bring across to them oh its claim with
that money Rumble if your lesson and
brother do not do it it'll be Casanova
situation don't daddy violence toward
score for your winners no no but we we
cannot confirm and not confirm things
may happen what goes on in LA stays in
LA what will happen is you know this is
this complete scenario obviously but you
know someone comes out there and they're
like I got a Scorpio king day and
looking like I got a scorpion the quick
to dress is a wrap Oh mr. Singh this was
definitely of the ASCO and hopefully
you're gonna say Oh Microsoft can really
make this right you know we understand
this is privileged and everybody likes
to take advantage of and they tried to
change format but um they gotta make it
right they gotta make it right the way
it was handled the delay and um you know
lack of communication afterwards was was
was a little less to be desired but I
will see what happens we got our fingers
crossed I got everybody got they lucky
rabbit's foot and holy stuff wednesday
ford new to the next one now talk to me
i do want to say right now that if some
is so people really do get Jack for
their score pills
it wasn't okay oh I can say is follow
that followed the flight cancellation
and bookings lord King please LA in two
days oh well okay let me rephrase that
if someone Scorpio give back it was not
all the Lord's that start with a day
thank you they just happen to be there
and saw what happened allegedly
allegedly fellas I do want to say that
regardless what have is this Wednesday
you know you know any gamer low will you
know gamers are on the world they III is
like a dream why you know it's something
that for the longest time isn't even
obtainable like you never think you'll
ever go to it but you know I have to
give Microsoft thing last year they made
that dream come true to me so you know
regardless what happens like I can't
take from the fact that last year I
gotta go to one of the things I've
wanted to go my entire life because of
these people we will all love to go to
fan fest this year hell yeah but you
know if I don't if I don't get it go
it's not the end of the world it sucks
but you know there's still bethesda
there you know that there's a couple
other things that you know you could go
to but i really want to go to this know
that this is I mean like I said for
those who haven't gone you know in Lord
can I really feel bad for right now for
love song because if he doesn't get a
chance to go he won't get a chance to
experience what we experienced and it's
just a premium experience it's just is
something to be said about having fill
out there and all stage don't be get
being in that lunch room beforehand the
anticipation it not just eat three so
even the events after you know I mean
like Microsoft really does a good job
you know setting things up in law ruler
and more cardio they'd also like prior
to that you know in 2015 like they
rented out a whole club
they have like the developers did I was
when gears of war on the remaster was
there and fours and we were right on the
you know the floor talking the Ferguson
and these guys and they had games and
you know it's a good time you know
alcohols flowing and little music and it
it's just it is so inviting like I can't
describe it's just you feel like your
arm and arm with the developers and fail
and you feel part of that xbox family
and its really unlike any experienced I
have so it's like to not have that can I
have experienced least I've experienced
it to not experience it sucks you know
and then the to think that you want it
and feel not experiencing you know I
mean like that's what people don't
understand you know and like I said it
was not out hmm I need to give a shout
out to EA for doing their fan fest and
everything going off without a hitch you
know down not up that out to EA with
that confirmation that can't do for my
email right on site with no problems
shut up avoid like you are the real MVP
yeah really something real quick oh yes
oh man walk it out for free Scorpio get
jump for a Scorpio I will fight for the
death though reclaim your asses I also
if um would eat three vouchers be
sufficient enough would that be
sufficient so I already got one what I
happen with the people already got one I
leave my hundred and fifty dollars I
don't care I don't think they would do
that just the fact that you could buy
them this year I don't think they have
as many III tickets to fly around like
it last year what in a defense though
because you know as we as as of right
now e to Texas to the village they've
not sold out so people all got the 250
no not yet people don't get that 250 and
then the fly out so it's not under the
realm of possibility to say hey we can
give you an e3 ticket it is a disrespect
to comic-con this is no comic-con right
no suspense or better have a free
Scorpio and a Persian stripper if it is
after this crazy a dick
it's a go while we gonna move on we got
everything now Microsoft please make it
right and for everybody jumping in it is
Wednesday you know you know hopefully
everybody gets and we'll see what
happens but we are going to move on Lord
sovereigns you want to talk about switch
gang and some stuff that Grampa
nintendo's been doing late let's go no
switch gag grandfather what's happening
I'm comment end those strikes again man
always rear their ugly head ok so what I
wanted to talk about this weekend breaks
the Lord's was basically the the rumors
that a surfaced and at this point it
seems like they're more fact than
anything because a few outlets saying
the same thing that there's going to be
an SNES classic edition coming out
towards the holidays of this year um so
what I want to talk about was basically
what that sort of means for SNES games
coming out on Virtual Console for the
switch later on and what in if what and
how that affects those games coming out
to virtual console um and then basically
the question Nintendo has this thing
with it they really they know that their
fan base is gonna constantly follow them
and they kind of constantly support
whatever archaic um you know archaic
like policies and systems that they
implemented it into their systems in
terms of having to pay multiple times
for games instead in the same games on
different systems so my questions The
Lord's is can they continue to do this
with regular consumers not not hardcore
Nintendo fans and still continue to be
successful can they can they keep nickel
and diming people and get away with it
with anybody except the hardcore so
that's what I love y'all go jumping on
it for me it's like I get it because
it's like the NES classic obviously
we've seen the success of it you know
everybody's like okay well why they
discontinued in it you know this makes
no sense and I agree i'm it's definitely
you know something that's is churning
out a lot of money i was surprised them
to walk away from it now when i found
out why because they're gonna do a Super
NES class
that was a lot yeah well only concerns
now is that because of this and this is
where I think I know you I'm you may be
going most often is that I'm concerned
that now all this does is just delay
Virtual Console more because I'm like
does this not mean I'm gonna get Virtual
Console soon because you want to make a
profit off of us are miniaturized
emulator okay that does sound looking at
it right now so it's just like you know
look is it okay look so good no no I see
it being delayed absolutely but I think
it won't be as long as you might assume
to talk to sort of let an SNES clas
classic shine because yeah I've come to
believe after after all this the
cancellation of NES classic and and and
sort of the rumors of this they don't
care they don't care because what
they're gonna do is they're gonna give
you the SNES classic right those games
are going to be isolated to that system
there's going to be no sort of online
functionality they're gonna be like okay
and you can get these games piecemeal on
switch virtual virtual console with
online play what all that stuff that
will promise him before right and
they're not gonna care yeah i can not
conceding individual like me you put
some old legend of zelda zon they're
like I bought that [ __ ] like six times
I'm will go into my they know we're
gonna buy it you know my whole thing is
just that having these systems as a
separate entity I'm just concerned that
it just delays us getting it on the
switched fast not saying that it's not
gonna come to the switch I'm saying like
I want virtual console now like to me
you know let's be honest yes Zelda is
great they've got a lot of things
announce each month got mario kart
coming you know this week you know I get
it so it looks like you know there's a
major release every other month sprinkle
with indeeds right excuse me sorry I had
to blow my nose there but between Indies
and all these other stuff so it's just
like you know all i want is virtual
console between these releases like that
would be perfect no to have like you
know a couple of old games to just throw
back
on and do all that stuff you know so
that des is my Microsoft that virtual
console would have been great between
now I'm like an e3 announcement and I'm
just concerned that come III we're not
gonna get it but that's that's all I
think they're gonna um route I think
they're gonna release the virtual
console I think they're going to release
the Super NES mini all at the same time
um mother 3 I don't think they care I
think oh how did it feel is you got dead
and this is what they would do right
let's say you can pick up the virtual
that the little Super NES mini for 60
bucks with the 30 games built it yay of
the human race [ __ ] it's not 60 bucks
and now what is what oh whatever
whatever the prices okay Oh earthbound
okay all right ask hmm I say it's a
Hyundai know whatever yay um they're
gonna put all those games on for 16
bucks on virtual costs all 30 of those
games if you wanna get them yep mmm they
don't care if you're gonna buy you know
I don't think they acted as as as if SP
has minier ops you think they're gonna
do that because I mean when did the NES
courteous fantastic that we still
haven't got no virtual console or
anything it may be well oh you got to
think about it also on the switch wasn't
really ready for that with the armed
user interface it wasn't ready it
doesn't have netflix doesn't have a lot
of stuff um into it so they're gonna
start implementing those things right
now remember this is grandpa Nintendo's
this is benjamin buttons you know and
he's learning on the go I'm impressed
with how fast he's learning I our way
with the download the patches the tendon
attaches they're like whoa I was excited
I like I got the farmer man patched it
jumped my game is 60 frames per second
I'm like
are you Graham find antenna what will it
what's going on in these streets is you
know times now yeah I'm pursuing this
with the willingness to learn definitely
yes the showing that they're showing
that they have to be different they
can't be the same but they're gonna stay
grounded in their roots their rules
ought to rip your wallet out of your
pocket and don't have regard for you
like game that you say okay that should
be six dollars is 995 to fortune bus
like what are you doing like where are
you at with yourself if ya ba made it
like what ya know my name is Vic dollars
know bout me are ya what do you got
hours of something read it's not this
way title that you oh yeah I'm about yes
sir yes look at that I have that day
what yeah I used to play that game on
turbo graphics 16 trihard with the motel
town okay no oj oj got tap with five
players in Solomon or men's atom bombs
at it like ball medicine has a thing
know that I know I your young G but that
is a classic like you don't have known
indeed like I brought the turbo graphics
over i bought the turbo graphics / law
cognito brought the extended though the
what was that the 60 more days happy he
brought the tap everybody has to body
own controllers I came with three
controllers we had 16 players playing
long man so down horrible graphics now
to your point load addict will I'm not
so I'm not justifying saying it was
worth 60 now I'm just saying that it's a
classic inside bro I remember playing
bomberman on the the n64 Oh playing the
UH the split of the split screen or yes
it's the ultimate party game and like i
said this way they had a lot co-op modes
my stuff but love by bomb again looking
sorry get [ __ ] nintendo stuff well
you know
nintendo is known to have total
disregard for your wallet so I can I in
knowing these guys I know day today
they're going to drop the system and
they're going to draw a virtual console
because they're not going to produce a
lot of these systems you systems and
novelty systems so they're going to
produce a novelty system there's not
supposed to coexist with any of their
our online systems on their engaged
system as far as 3ds or the switch those
are engage systems these systems that
they dropping is novelty cutoff systems
that they producer a finite amount of
them and once that's that shipment sells
out they don't tell you that they they
tell you that you can keep buying it
because they want to discourage
resellers but resellers already know
once i get it i can up the price up an
extra three hundred dollars and then
resell it so that's what happened with
the super with the nes mini it's not
happen with the super nes minions gonna
happen with the gamecube many is going
to happen with all the little minis that
they're coming out with and they're
gonna do it because that's gentle listen
they know what they want in 10 though
they know that we're gonna buy and they
know that these things are successful
you know it just like i said just my
only concern is I just didn't want it to
stumble any development with the switch
because I really like what's going on a
switch but I would you say I mean
they're going to do it it's it it is
what it is with a you're good good lord
I don't know if you guys jumped in massa
well look like I got completely like I
said before and then and then um lord
King echo dad yeah they got they're not
gonna care because it's gonna be a
closed-off system and again like they
promised all this different
functionality with all these games come
in a virtual console with online plane
and stuff like that and that's what
they're going to use as a reason as a
differentiator they're gonna say no it's
not the same it's different this is
something completely different and this
is um you know this is this is a just
something that we put out there you know
as a nostalgia bid and that's that um I
think they need they they should be a
little more forthcoming about how long
these products going to be on the mark
before they before they anywhere like
they did and ceremoniously with the UH
with the UM with the NES classic but I
think with Esther years oh yeah yeah
yeah I think with the I think what they
realize though that I think this is
gonna be around a lot longer a lot
longer because yeah these games hold up
better than any yeah I agree I agree
that I guess I guess to your point I
guess that's why I'm a little frustrated
so that's why it bothered me because I
like thats the emulator that I really
would angry because Super Nintendo I
have so many positive and I was my first
Nintendo system really that i purchased
and I'll never forget launching to tell
you like I remember going to his crib
like it was yesterday and seeing f0 for
the first time he had the Japanese
Famicom Super Famicom he had it before
the States we went to his crib and I
said what is happening with gaming when
was it mode 7 it was motorcycle battery
yeah of 0 and I'm super mario at my
house and I'm Paula rings I'm never
gonna forget it because you got the
miles 27 a.m. in the morning and it was
you and shout out to oh lord how was
dinner it was out here no it wasn't ha
it was um a whole bunch of North I can
evade a king dru it was just one Lord
that came with you that morning oh I'll
basketball oh oh was it lost yes Lord oh
Lord all is in the building yea Lord off
with you I'll never figure but I got a
god my question to you look I've needle
hmm seeing the value in the Super NES
mini yes would you still do virtual
console or would you just pick up a
little mini that has the 30 games on it
I just want I'm be honest these minis
don't do anything for me I mean less I
like the phone a portable
yeah I like the physical aesthetic of it
looks cute yeah I remember when I had
that that's nice I got the English the
new ish can do this so I want it all my
switch I want to be F zero in on a
switch on the goal I want to just be
able to take those old games with me and
remember again this is my first Nintendo
system in a while you guys have had the
luxury of having wheeze and you guys
know what virtual consoles about I don't
like this is my first I know I have a
purchase oh I'll caddy know and it I
just did some research was sovereign
like I guess on the wii they had the
shinobi RK joint that i got in the crib
now remember we might go kart wii
virtual console to greatest yes virtual
console has shinobi arcade version i
look at my avatar right now in this chat
that's one of my family games of all
time yours and so we had that I got the
arcade stand alone in my crib looking at
Lu yeah we got pictures all of us on the
Lord's I bought that game you know I
mean that's how much i love shinobi
arcade the arcade version so to have all
that library I'm like I want to announce
it announcer drawer like that's where
I'm at with this I don't care about
these little remix low systems in the
side that's nice but it's no doubt I
want my switch man I stop I agree I if I
could get my hands on an SNES classic
and just put it up on the shelf fine but
beyond that yeah I want it on my switch
what's all I'm saying well yes there's a
good one what attic you cool with the
with the MIDI or I mean about the mini
okay that's his answer is yes so we good
over your SNES stuff and Grandpa
nintendo stuff so we can move on and
lord King we've got a controversial test
with uh yeah Oh next case well let's
just say this is let's let's let's keep
a spade a spade everybody that picked a
playstation 4 purchase a roach motel the
fact that Mike fact I've come out yes
justice there was a pervert system of
roaches and it's nice it's warm it has a
little heat inside for the roaches and
some some memes that I've been spreading
around sure little beds for roaches it's
not your place taking my question like
PlayStation it are you happy with your
roach motel it it's boy is back come on
this is actual no this is not a joke
this is not me disparaging your console
oh my console because I got to Roach
Motels in my house this and I look at
them kind of funny right now because I'm
do i put a combat in the back of them
[ __ ] me [ __ ] the PlayStation fours with
a combat inside the box this is all
audio track them roaches oh my i don't
like roaches I don't want oh is it a
problem that you know it's a the prefer
console for roaches yes I'm done with
you learn Atticus loving I could jump
about this guy looks looks of it you
guys have just listen III consider and
that I keep a clean home so my why I
hope with it I don't have and if I do
stay in and die in there and don't come
oh but I again I my system is working
fine so now little bit oh yeah I mean
obviously I saw the news it was a bit
humorous obviously you know in the issue
of fairness you know most
you know as a tech you know people knows
you go to people's homes and are you
send people stuff gonna send you stuff
prepared who knows what you're fine when
you open the innards but I thought it
was kind of funny that the way the UM
the texts that were actually repairing
pants for us we're talking I came was
like the perfect you know housing based
on the warmth where the capacitors are
the way things I don't just find this
thing amazing like that that was kind of
fun I it so yeah you know it is what it
is it's one of those things where it's
just like for whatever reason to design
I guess they get access and they like it
there but uh I want extra king about his
second part of his thing or his topic
which was about the slim right and you
wanted to talk about you know did you
feel like there was a need for a door
someone with something that if it was a
it was such a question well my question
was um being that the pro is out and
we've seen it in action and we see what
its gonna what it can do is it necessary
knowing that the probe hasn't lived up
to expectations in my opinion have an
Onan one and should I had stayed Pat
with my regular PlayStation 4 because it
seems like everything is geared towards
the regular playstation 4 anyway is the
pro necessary and today is is is it it
wasn't warranted hmm that's what my
shops are doing Lord addict will you get
with the program the pro hours of care
oh that's a little bit more specifically
when you go to the prolite it's just
gonna be the thing i buy above the ps4
like if the pro woulda came out our to
got a ps4 like I don't really put the
games I want to play on the PlayStation
I don't really thinks gonna get like you
know it don't really matter to me like I
want to play kingdom hearts that's what
i want so like regardless what I get on
playing kingdom hearts like I get what
they're saying but you know when you see
digital foundry like completely pick it
apart it's like is it worth the extra
money mm-hmm
naw fleetlord a command he's actually um
jumping anything he's already seeing the
result of the pro and the fanboy
arguments so um yeah I mean for me it's
like one of those things which at the
time I was very interested you know when
it when it was announced just to see I'm
attacking what I know what's the most
powerful things out there I want to you
know see what's good but you know to
Lord and commands credit you know the
jumps haven't been as significant for me
um the other thing is let's be honest
with the announcement the problem with
the probe for me was always this it's
not that it was like garbage or anything
like that it's just that we knew coming
into that something better was on the
horizon right we knew during the it was
born under the shadow of Scorpio being
this eventual thing that would surpass
it so now when we know what Scorpio is
now and that you see in the benchmarks
and digital foundry going into it it's
kind of tough you know for a person who
hasn't had the pro and I'ma be honest
the other thing that kind of killed the
probe again it's just north of NATO
speaking for himself I was ready to get
my probe at as Lords no more why I sold
my ps4 standard to Lord SWAT you know
him in the wifey they wanted a ps4 I
figured I'm gonna get my ps4 a bag with
just a dead spell at the time and i
figured i was getting the pro right
during that time scorpion nouncement
during that time switch so that money
went there so that I've got my switch
and I'm enjoying it I'm saving my money
obviously clearly for the Scorpio I'm
trying to justify for myself okay to get
the pro now I can't really justify and
the last point I want to make with the
pro is just that you know my sovereign I
was talking out his conversation with
you before is that you know I'm a fork
with 4k HDR gang right for the most most
most of the Lord's in here so yes know
when ice looked at their list digital
foundry to the breakdown of all the ps4
pro games and like half of them wasn't
using HDR and I'm like that's ridiculous
you know and then it's like you know
some games here you know you the
checkerboard mountain ken long as the
check button you know does
gets the resolution looking great and on
a 4k it's close to 4k native I don't
really mind it but what I do mind is
you're not getting that 4k 60 studies
like UK like like final fantasy they did
a breakdown like 30 frames per second
here you might get chattering here like
so you got a tinker with settings so I
still don't feel that you know big jump
it kind of does feel like a half measure
and the last point I'll make is what
Phil said was that they were going to
come up with a Scorpio during that year
but they felt that you know what was in
place wouldn't be enough to do their
initial goal which is you know 4k across
the board all day everything so that's
just where I'm at with it you know am i
knocking people forgetting it you know
may I eventually still pickin when it's
possible but right now I can't justify
it not would Scorpio on horizon and last
time I slips off that's where i met with
it well what's up look at this glow
sovereign do you have anything to chime
in on this yeah I mean for me I've
always been is it is it is a pro
necessity no for for someone like me I
always like to try to be at the
forefront of any type of any type of
tech coming out so you know when it
comes out I'll be one of the first you
know to kind of jump out and get it and
I there's growing pains that go along
with that so for me I was very aware
that what was coming what it was capable
of and but I knew I wanted to get a 4k
TV at the time and it just everything
kind of it was like a perfect storm to
get all these things at once and I said
well you know what I'm gonna I'm just
going to get the focus that's that's
what it is it's the most powerful
version of the PlayStation 4 it's the
best way to play playstation 4 games I
want to have it so that's again that's
just how I approach it um for the
average gamer and the average consumer
no it's not it's not a necessity um it
is absolutely a half-measure um what I
do think it did though it kind of I'm
not so sure how I feel about these kind
of mid-cycle refresh is moving forward
and what's going to happen beyond the
pro and what's going to happen be honest
scorpio and if they're going to continue
the sort of cadence with you know with
the next Xbox after Scorpio being a huge
leap and assuming that the next
PlayStation is going to be a huge leap
then what do we see after that um but I
think I think when you're talking about
I think my hope is that moving forward
all of the weather Sony whether it's
microsoft that they're taking the
mentality that you're your library needs
to move forward with you they have to
create this ecosystem that's flowing
from generation to generation and you
can't do that when you when you start
all over everyone six to eight year s
that is correct so it's important that
you maintain these these sort of these
sort of incremental improvements moving
forward should the jump moving forward
to the jump be bigger yeah the jump from
from initial beginning of a generation
to mid-cycle refresh should be more
along the lines of what the Scorpio is
it should be a considerable chop rare um
Laura muscle can I jump in what could
you made a point that I'm not gonna
forget yeah and you point about at first
we weren't being sure about um you know
the mid cycle my generation refresh
right right now ha what I wanted to
bring it as I'm very curious to see
because let's be on the way Scorpios
designed is different right and what
they're saying is that this is the first
time the hardware is being designed the
current engines that's in place and
according to digital ferny like you
really can't do that when you start with
a brand new generation refresh right so
I'm curious to see when Scorpio does
come out how these benefits really
affect because this will be the first
time that a system is being told to
current existing engines and getting the
best and optimizing the best out of it
now obviously more power is always
better and we know that but I'm just
saying I'm just curious to see how that
all plays out I want to get your
feedback on a convergent in reference to
the I don't notice i think what it's
going to do what it's going to do is
going to take a lot of the pressure off
the developers to making to making those
improvements themselves it was stated
that by doing that
creating a create eliminating those
bottlenecks and those limitations in
hardware on the silicon what it does is
that it allows Microsoft to handle that
and a lot of that stress and pressure is
taken off of the developer to make those
improvements and changes it's already
built it's already ingrained so a lot of
these as we said before all of these all
these developers have been developing
scalable games forever the games have
been coming out on multiple platforms
including pc so there's a high-end spec
already in place so what Microsoft is
saying look the base fact that you give
us for Xbox a data at a hardware level
we can improve that for Scorpio without
asking too much of you will handle it on
our end we'll take care of it and that's
really important when you talk about
support moving forward when you talk
about um you know how developers
perceive the the system in the ecosystem
moving forward is really important that
they take a lot of that pressure off of
them to do that and when you're saying
we could do it in hardware and we'll
take care of it ourselves that's a big
deal that's a biggie so and I think
that's something that Sony has to the
sony has to consider it moving forward
moving forward that's something to
absolutely have to consider and again to
be fair like when you talk about the pro
like they've already implemented stuff
like the SOC and stuff in the pro so
it's it's moving along those lines it's
just microsoft took it a few steps
further now it's going to be interesting
to see what PS five or whatever comes
after the pro does to try to improve
upon that because they have to they
absolutely have to so touching my breast
there mmm looking you want to jump on
the lead we cut you from this yeah no no
I was just um I was giving my wrap-up of
the summation of it um shout out to uh
mark cerny for robbing sony for what
he's done oh my god you all it was three
yeah he's gonna like it out on on these
fools he have y'all all full and
bamboozled um because listen unless
that's let's not get it twisted
Microsoft fumbled the football and you
guys came up behind they picked it up to
score the touchdown you ran out of the
way or for our mistake that's all I was
bro if we came out and we didn't put
that we did if Microsoft woulda lied to
you instead of being an upfront company
we wouldn't be where we are you wouldn't
be where you are gonna be finished you'd
be swimming with the fishes and mark
cerny will go down as another flop all
right he's gonna plug he's the neck it
is don't ever forget he brings to the
table neck I gotta ditch me of lacking a
guy be like the neck got a good luck sir
he's got some deep Sega time so i gotta
i gotta shut up that all right i don't
think that old saying i don't put that
on sega booty think i would really miss
against my channel for more sony
shoutout mark 34 sink and sega like he
gonna do sony all right this he has a
window out he brought the pro out mark
Cerny that's on your head instead of
actually pushing a real system this is
what happened when the weather is
abortion charge a boss put two projects
in he looked at one project and said
that's a half-measure let's not go there
let's go to full monty on him shout out
the field shout out to mark sorry for
saying let's do a half measure and let's
sink this ship because nobody's buying a
pro why why should you buy a pro when
you got to cheap a system there this
does the same exact thing for less
problem hmm low tech investor so looking
say are you basically say Saudis the
Atlanta Falcons of the Super Bowl this
game no actually no no no they they're
not the latter Falcons of the situation
actually they are the bed
fisheries they are the Patriots
Microsoft Excel an avowedly the JD and
he blew it hell out of the company we
choked it away so y'all sony yes yes
mark cerny right now he's fooling you
he's Tom Brady he's got it he's fooled
you you're fooled and Sony is looking at
these numbers like oh my god mark cerny
whatever you say go ahead yeah we gonna
go pro watch next year when the Scorpio
comes out this year next year Sonny's
gonna put our pro plus they'll be funny
i browbeat Northwester because of mark
cerny the neck man you are going in of
us I don't know it isn't you know why
cuz he's a smaller thin he's a charlatan
he's the snake oil a snake oil salesman
we know you I see straight through you
mark cerny they don't see through you
because you gave them sake and you Ernie
you put out neck and I know what you
about watching shout out the mark so you
don't always well good it's the first
yeah this time is over 88 neck man come
defend yourself on the podcast we're
waiting good or bad enough I feel good I
feel we're sentiments are as far as the
fruit oh lordy are they real of cry
letting commands asking for you by the
way so where you at with the I just went
a little bit more from you on the pro
let that's all it comes to the pro I
mean if you if you want you want it you
don't you don't I mean I've never know a
lot of talk about the pro it came out it
did what it was supposed to I guess and
you know people like it you know people
don't I mean in case you ain't noticed
the last time you guys even really hurt
hype about the pro I mean yep they never
hiked it themselves they I'm name they
made sure it a bit BB as low-key about
it as possible I mean in this they know
it was a half-measure crap this isn't
really like you know like i know a lot
of people want to watch this and think
it's like you know we're xbox fans just
[ __ ] on the playstation like look
like I I'm going to get a playstation
eventually because I want to play
kingdom hearts and you know final
fantasy 7 but it's going to come out
first on PlayStation and that's worth it
just there but I i will buy pro because
it's this it's the better product of the
tube but it's not like is a whole lot
better I mean I'm not gonna stay here
ematic like this thing is like this
Super Bowl football cuz it's not putting
any respect I'm just upset I'm coming
from a standpoint of purchasing two pros
alright so don't sit here and tell me
how you make it so template Union ya
know don't tell me that crap I don't
even hit it I got two pros know when
y'all to get one pro that you can judge
me shut up I don't want to hear anything
i gotta say i got tricks gave me know
what the greatest thing about this is
anchorman I got a timeout button you in
timeout I look like a 300 seconds oh so
you must put me on a time out last week
now you know I that's that's the first
time I've ever putting anyone on time
now that I really did dealer okay okay
I'll shout angrily nothing realize he's
gonna go to Twitter right he's the chat
is lit rayban widow but that'll solve
you good you got everybody's good on the
on the pro absolutely yeah we got on
that crow Sony's good on the pro oh my
god is my loose we carry your goodness
soda yesterday room yeah we got get Sony
guess cuz I want you to come in here
yeah y'all better come ahead with two
pros a better before you come at my
degree doing it I gotta get I gotta
holla a lot of bunches we gotta still
have it when he Saudi subjects shout out
the loaded bugs but on that note we got
another one in the books another great
show you know mechanic closeout shadaloo
agreement for making to chat live aquino
i'm also the homie um said his name cop
no Cole was in there tearing it up in
the chat today so we're gonna close out
so um let's get round the table brother
no attic another mother was going on
with you the Attic show where can people
find you and all that good stuff Tommy
on YouTube gaming a xbox room decal
playstation room to kill a bunch of
numbers on switch but I don't know them
yeah so chic you up yes steam game II
addict yeah I'm kind of a really
thrilled right now just put on come at a
time out I'm gonna really use that a lot
here Islands populace I'm silencing him
okay i believe is magically with ham
audience just deleted by our Lord
podcast message to the leader private
public I'm gonna hear it we are good if
it looks of wicked people not find you
people could not find me on xbox live at
being sovereign and a PSN bxr in one
word oh and quick shout-out to my
brother Lord Kaiser Lord kya baat sooo
happy birthday happy boy date ok before
they brothers now for your brother you
gotta get one social media for his
birthday yeah he's forcing me to each
question you gotta get you gotta get
your Twitter account don't listen don't
listen oh stop levels where you take
this girl down don't listen we gotta get
Louis off your beer for the people you
don't say get one ferrati Illuminati
where can people find you XS game your
farm on expert game beloved next game a
king david OTW on twitter instagram on
xbox live and on playstation they're
working to find me at xbox 360 level one
meet you until you're gonna keep going
on about
Parker coming to you yes sir peter
brothers in the building of course is
Lord cognito here you can find me on
social media Twitter is Lord Cognito and
shout out to playback gaming dotnet
dizzy and the boys they got articles
coming through shelter on our gym later
bella knows in those guys over there i'm
real games media always giving us love
and we appreciate your support you got a
lot of things still more cooking a lot
of great guests you have to eat three
thing coming down up down the horizon so
we got that going and appreciate your
blog that's gonna be live here we got
some surprises that's gonna be real fun
a lot of fun things going on for that
and I'm shouted jack pitiless we got a
lot of things going on to chat right now
and I really want to shout out to God
really getting out there except for
anchor so we're not shouting in now
shout out the Lord anchorman for support
loves getting out there do it k my
podcast is not affiliated with his
statement he just said oh good yeah a
little tussle that's our brethren right
there but um we still a bad part that's
[ __ ] sorry man I mean support us know
your itunes soundcloud still you know we
stock still get a last request i'm
seeing the numbers out there
everything's rising and we building slow
and it all starts with cha so show us
some love and on that note we are out
peace alright